so i'm predicting king to g2 yep  covering the h1 square and how's going  for  a desperate counter attack is lost long  term with the two missing pawns of  course  and carlson's trying to take  keep control  and uh  they've reached move 39  so 105 seconds oh but this is it now  castle is forcing the end game  and the a pawns will queen  so the world champion wins his  armageddon game  yeah more or less convincingly i would  say i think he  dominated  big parts of it  and chose this yeah flying he had some  experience with and  find how it got under pressure on the  clock at on the board yeah  seems like  the computer is saying after knight e5  this point to b5 was indeed the way  it takes takes pawn to  b4 with a mess